hello everyone and welcome to game 14 of
the 1921 World Chess Championship match
between Emanuele Alaska and josé raúl
capablanca this is the last game of the
championship match and I would just like
to congratulate everyone who's been here
from the beginning of the capablanca
saga it's been quite a journey I myself
learned to really a lot about the great
cube and I hope you did as well and
there is a reason why I'm recording with
shades but I will mention that at at the
end of the video so without further ado
this is game 14 Alaska opens with E for
like in the previous games with E 5 by
capablanca Knight f3 Knight to c6 and of
course the rule opus is on the board
Bishop to b5 with Knight to f6 the
Berlin defence by capablanca and now
castles by Lasker with D 6 and D for
Bishop to d7 unpinning and developing
the LightSquared Bishop Knight to c3 and
now Bishop to e7 Capablanca is ready to
Castle kingside and here
nowadays we would probably see something
like rook to e1 but in those days Bishop
captures and c6 was the way to go
so Bishop captures and now Queen to d3
defending the e4 pawn with a capture Sun
d4 Knight captures on d4 a putting
pressure on the bishop and now Bishop to
d7 for the moment capablanca keeps the
bishop fair with Bishop to g5 by Lasker
and couple Blanca castles King side rook
81 by Lasker and here there is h6 a year
after this match was played a couple
Blanca had this exact same position with
the white pieces he played against
Hamilton Hamilton tried Knight to g4 in
this position but capablanca want a very
nice game with white here so here couple
Blanca plays h6 which is in fact a
better move Bishop to h4 and now Knight
2h7 just offering a trade of Bishops
Bishop character's Queen captures and
now Knight to d5 last forgets this d5
square for his Knight with an attack on
the Queen so he will get
c4 without wasting any time Queen back
to d8 and now c4 and here Alaska has an
excellent position those two knights are
really awesome a couple onthe says that
black is okay but black has to be very
careful for example if you try to kick
away the night with c6
right away then you leave the week this
exponent you're not really gonna get it
away from the d6 due to the c4 in d5
points regarding the d5 square so here
after let's say in 93 white will go
Knight f5 to go after the d6 pawn for
example rook e8 and now Knight d2 f5
you're going after the d6 pawn bishop
characteris Knight captures the other
night now attacks the d6 pawn as well
and I look the e6 and while you can play
this it's very ugly and kappa blanka
says it's he doesn't want to play this
would with black white and just easily
continue attacking the d6 pawn and even
after Knight f6 is going after the e4
pawn rook F e1 defends it and still
white will be better so here a couple
Blanca plays rook e8 and now last pair
plays f4 really changing the structure
of the of the position and but on the
other hand it allows kappa blanka now to
play c6 because Lasker opened up this
diagonal which will favour a couple
Blancas Queen here a couple Lanka play
c6 but now it's a bit different now if
we tried the same idea 93 to f5 you get
Queen to b6 and now this diagonal is
open so white will have to waste a move
king h1 now you get nice to f6 and now
the same idea no longer applies if you
play Knight to f5 you just get d5 and
the black who gets rid of his backwards
deep on as the knight now nicely guards
the d5 square so last but retreats the
c3 and the now Queen to b6 again taking
control of this diagonal and also
putting pressure on the b2 point last
replace b3 he gets rid of this weakness
and now rook a to d8 Capablanca says
that this is maybe a waste of time but
it's again one of those cases were kappa
blanka says his movies a waste of time
but it is in fact we recommended by the
engine he says maybe rook east 7
followed by rook e8 doubling up on the
e-file instantly would have been better
but ok rook a to the 8th and now came to
h1 Lasker wants to unpin he doesn't want
to have his knight paralyzed on d4
forever Knights to f6 by kappa blanka
going after the e4 pawn and now even
though last press Alaska control
more Center his eforp on is a week and
now Capablanca will do whatever he can
to undermine it with h3 taking away the
g4 square from Cabo Blancas pieces
Bishop to c8 we have rook to d1 a couple
of one cat doesn't like this move he
says that black should somehow go for a
King side attack or something and look
for his chances there but what are you
gonna do again rook to d1 last Christmas
is the top move recommended by the
engine so it's not only a couple month
if he says his own moves are a waste of
time he also thinks that about other
people's moves which are of course in
this case the strongest moves but okay
rookie seven now Capablanca shifts to
his plan of doubling up on the e-file
with rook fe1 and now rook dt 8 putting
pressure on the e4 pawn and now rook to
eat ooh we have Queen to a5 now
capablanca wants to shift the Queen over
to the Kings side with Queen to h5 so
rook to f1 Queen to h5 da - point is
guarded so there's nothing to do there
and now kink the g1 you don't want your
King on the same file as the Queen to
allow some 90g for ideas maybe with a
six by kappa blanka and now look after
rook F - f - we have Queen to g6 by
capablanca now again with attacking the
point four times and also clearing this
h5 square for the knight if needed then
the knight maybe can come to g3 maybe it
can attack f4 at some point depending on
what Lasker plays and here last replace
Roop to f3 Capablanca mentions that
Knight a5 although it seems interesting
could be could be dangerous for example
if Bishop captures an f5 pawn captures
on f5 and now Queen to h5 g 4 attacks
the queen but the Queen has a safety
square on h4 so Queen to h4 and now you
will play something like King to g2 and
black black the does not mind this
position so after the screen to g6 we
have rook to f3 by Lasker and now comes
Queen to h5 with f5 and here kappa
blanka says that ok
you do lock his life for a better part
of the game but
on the other hand you leave the e5
square open for a couple bonkers pieces
for example maybe then I can go to be 75
would be very strong so he likes it but
he doesn't like it here Queen to h4
again freeing the h5 square for the
knight the knight can now come to f4 if
needed to try and form the key a Queen
and the rook and here at last cars best
course of action is probably rook after
e3 just doubling up on the e-file and
forcing capablanca to look for some some
ideas here
but Alaska played King to h2 here and it
doesn't work last pair probably had some
sort of an idea that if capablanca makes
some sort of a silly mood and he can
play g3 for the Queen back and play rook
to f4 but a couple Blanca of course as
you can imagine did not play a useless
move Capablanca played a different move
just to show you Knight captures on e4
doesn't work if Knight captures on e4
then g3 is very strong and this was in
fact last great idea
because then you get Knight captures and
c3g captures on h4 and now Knight
captures an e2 so Capablanca would grab
a lot of material here but it would
still it would still favor white for
example f6 f6 by white attacking the
rook and now you would get rook to e4
getting into row Calloway Knight
captures I need to look captures I need
to with check and King to g1 and here
it's just black did achieve something
but not all that much here what a white
would still be better so here a couple
Blanca played a different move and
you're welcome to pause the video and
try to find this we can call it a
winning idea for a couple Blanca maybe
not right away but feel feel feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
best move for kappa blanka in this
position so for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations
you have just won the World Chess
Championship title and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
capablanca play Knight to g4 check and
it does make sense as it comes with
check and now the night is coming to e5
without wasting any time which means you
are when
the exchange Alaska played king - h1 and
mountain Knights the e5 the Queen and
rook are under attack with Queen to d2
and now just Knight captures on f3 with
Knight captures on f3 and queen back to
f6 Queen to g3 Capablanca also mentions
there was possible but could be could be
somewhat dangerous so he prefers to
bring the Queen back with Queen to f6
and it's not that Lasker just wandered a
piece there is there is much poison in
this position for example couple on
conventions that you could try you could
try a lot of different approaches here
for example you could try something like
g4 and then after capablanca strikes on
the Queen side which he prepared it
would be 5 then you play e5 and here
black has to give back the exchange
because if you capture with the pawn
Knight e4 traps Capablanca Queen the
Queen has nowhere to go so here you
would you would have to give back the
exchange with rook captures but then you
just get Knight captures rook captures
and couple Blanca is very comfortable
playing this position being being up
upon so Alaska doesn't like his chances
there instead instead of going for the
exchange he plays a 4 he prevents
Capablanca counter play on the Queen
side would be 5 and now just g6 going
after the pawn here you have to do
something about it as you don't want to
allow all the traits here so F captures
and g 6f captors and g6 and now already
Capablanca has a threat of Bishop
captures on h3
which would free the knife or captures
so rook to e3 just defending the knight
and now worship the f5 capablanca now
piles up on the e4 pawn and here we have
Queen to d3
there is a very interesting line also
kappa blanka mentions it in his book
rooked the d3 going after the d6 pawn
instead and then you get this line
Bishop captures rook captures with an
attack on the Queen Queen g7 and
mountain Knights to h4 preparing to
capture the bishop and capture on g6 to
win to win the Queen but then black
plays Bishop f5 you get Knight captures
G captures and the rook captures on h6
this seems very dangerous for Capablanca
if last we went for this but luckily
Capablanca has rook e1 check King h2 and
Queen to e5 check g3 and now that the
second rank has been freed for
Capablanca rooks now Kabul Lanka had in
store Queen captures on c3 just a nice
Queen sacrifice to prepare mate because
if you capture you get a rook to eat you
mate and if you don't capture for
example if white goes for coming g5
check tries to make you the black queen
is in time to prevent checks the white
has no longer any attacking options here
and you are just down a whole row if you
try rook g6 to hurt when the Queen then
you again get made a troop to eat you
mate
so a couple bunker so all of this after
Bishop to a5 and Alaska of course so it
so he didn't go for route to d3 he
played Queen to d3
but now g5 with Knights to d2
bringing more defenders to the e4 pawn
and now Russia back to g6 bring the F
file for the queen with B for now white
wants the exchange as many points as
possible on the Queen side we have
Quinta east six and an outcomes b5 as
planned with a character say captures
and a now Capablanca brings the rook
over to the a file going for rook to a1
check Alaska prevents this with Queen to
be one and now Queen to e5 a nice
centralizing move with the Queen you're
pressuring the night here if the knight
moves it then rook to a1 still an idea
you're just gonna win the Queen so Queen
II won by last score last prepares Queen
to g3 to trade Queens and try to hold
the position being down the exchange
King - h7 by capablanca first improving
the position of his king bee captures be
captures and now Queen to g3 offering
the Queen trade and Capablanca says you
are not holding this position with Queen
captures rook captures into now rook to
a3
pinning the night as the rook on g3 is
undefended so keep the h2 defending the
rook and now rook the b7 here Kappa
Blancas threat is rope to be - this
would win the night just to give you an
example for example if you play
something like let's say King King - h1
or something then rugby - attacks the
night and the night has nowhere to go
your pawns
are preventing your knight from escaping
if you go neither 3 then the rook no
longer controls the c3 Knight
so you just capture it and if you try a
knight f1 it's a very nice idea rooks II
to a double attack on the night and
after the knight moves you just capture
capture and after rook captures and g3
you're just going to recapture yes you
are going to recapture sorry seems-seems
the interface froze for some reason no
idea why this happened really really
just just weird but yeah okay here we
are
so after this idea we said that after
nice capture sin g3 rook c1 just pins
the night and attacks it so after Luke -
b7 Alaska plate c5 he had cleared the
c-4 square for his Knight and now we get
D captures on c5 by capablanca Knight to
c4 attacking the rook and now rook to a1
with Knight to e5 and here comes rook
the c1 Capablanca says that a student of
the game should really study the
movements of the rook here as there are
s Capablanca says there are a few moves
that would be better than this one rook
the c1 a small improvement recommended
by the engine is a bishop - eh just
dominating white's night here probably
to defend the c6 pawn as well but
capablanca plan works just as well as
capablanca decided to give up the c6
pawn as you'll see in the game so look
the c1 attacking the knight here so the
rook is stuck guarding it with h4 and
now capablanca says that the stage has
been set for his idea rook to e7 now
attacking this knight Knight captures on
c6 and now rook to a 6 attacking the
knight once again Knights to d8 and now
G captures on h4 the idea is that if
Knight captures do you capture this with
check and then you pick up the c3 Knight
as well so lastly of course cannot
afford this with rook to d3 and now rook
to f6
now Alaska says that his control a
couple more
kappa blanka says at his control of the
F file ensures that Alaska has no more
tricks left up his sleeve Rudy seven
check King to h8 now controlling the f7
of square and now Knights the d5
attacking the rook but rook F to F 1 now
threatening rook to H 1 mate as the G 3
square is covered by the pawn so Alaska
has to run with King 2 H 3 and now
Bishop captures on e4 and in fact it was
in this position unmoved 56 that
Emmanuel has resigned the game and we
have a new world champion josé raúl
capablanca
the recent last pair resigned here is
that well whatever you do the thread is
Bishop to 5 which comes with check and
picks up your rook and if you do
something about that
still the bishop can come to f5 take
away the g4 square you can again
threaten mate
so probably King captures on h4 to get
out of mate and then you get Bishop
captures rook captures and you threaten
either rook cd1 or Rock FD 1 you can
even play this rook just to trade more
pieces and the only way to avoid trades
is to check and then maybe defend the
night but then the c4 pawn will for
example win the game if 95 go after the
PO now you just spin the night and then
if check you're gonna go King g8 and now
again you can't move the rook I mean you
have to move the rook to defend the
night you can't move the knight because
you lose the rooks Oh rookie 7 but now
just see three and if 90 g4 you get out
of the way now you get rook h1 check
King g3 see - now there's no stopping c1
even if white wins something let's say
Knight f6 sure King f8 you're gonna win
some material but then finally
capablanca brings the Queen into the
game and that's that of course Laster
knew all this and after Bishop captures
on e4 he resigned the game so yeah
that's the last game game 14 Capablanca
wins the series with 4 wins 10 draws and
0 losses so that's quite an
accomplishment taking away the World
Chess Championship title without a
single loss but something Glasper pretty
much saw coming as if we remember if
you've watched the negotiations video
last girl already said that he no longer
wishes to be
champion that he wants to give up his
title to capablanca and he would like to
fight him in this match as challenger
but yeah we're gonna talk a bit more
about this what comes after this in a
separate video as a lot of you requested
that we do a conclusion of the couple
Blanca saga in a separate with a video
so that's what we're gonna do when I
regain my eyesight back and the reason
why I'm wearing shades is I have some
sort of an eye condition so I didn't
want my zombie like appearance to
distract you from all the chests so that
that's why the shades are there now but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Bradley
Nixon Eamon Shakib Oliver leek Dogg
McNabb and law office John Butler for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos ER
think all for watching and I will see
you soon I will pretty much be just
checking up on your suggestions as until
I really regain my sight I'm not gonna
do the conclusion of the capablanca saga
so feel free to suggest anything and I'm
just gonna do videos based on your
suggestions yeah thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day